all right nerds Deadpool too is coming
into your theater soon and unless you've
been living under an infinity stone for
the past few years you know how exciting
that is Deadpool combines the relentless
charm of Ryan Reynolds the looks of an
overcooked pizza and the gratuitous body
count of the Man of Steel but if you
somehow don't know the difference
between Deadpool and Boat Wilder which
we understand because they're super
similar here are some things you need to
know about Wade Wilson and why he's the
biggest bleep ass out there he has an
accelerated healing factor yes it's like
Wolverines they're also both Canadian
but wait is taller and fewer people like
him also only has one indestructible
bone in the comics he got his powers
from the Weapon X program okay look he
al Vereen have a lot in common
it's like comic book writers only have
so many ideas Deadpool hosted the Venom
symbiote just after spider-man did you
won't see that in the movie though
because those rights would be impossible
to sort out wait doesn't always play
well with others but he has teamed up
with the x-force and had his own squad
mercs for money but he still won't take
the x-men's calls that's definitely it
it's not that they don't actually want
him around what do they tell you
Deadpool has the handwriting of an angel
his biggest fear is cows that's not
ridiculous have you have you ever really
looked at a cow
baffle stairs auntie huh
Deadpool gets all his weapons from his
buddy weasel whose real name is
jackhammer but he doesn't use that name
in the movies because it's way cooler
than weed Wilson I pays to be the star
in addition to his quick healing wait
his super fast reflexes speed and
agility but they don't always work a lot
of guys have that problem sometimes
alright Wade can speak Japanese German
Spanish and Esperanto which lets him
play himself in international printings
of the comics his most formidable
superpower is the ability to annoy
anyone if Domino can count luck he's
taking this now that you're totally
oversold go see Deadpool - yes this was
an ad why else do you think people make
these things
[Music]
you